this is going to be good here we go
so first of all yeah we can't even see
that barely you're not going to have to
watch that's 16 candles that's the last
scene in 16 candles
the last
it's a lot of food i think we can't no i
know what it is it's uh harold and kumar
they're playing salary yeah
it's white castle yes white castle
that is uh hereditary oh no
uh pulp fiction
oh i got it i got it
spongebob square butt whoa yeah wow m
m's i don't know oh wait it's uh it's an
audience 1970s uh mcdonald's
but it's a movie right it's like a
feature film
1970s mcdonald's i don't know is this
it's
uh past mr potato head you know this is
really mean to do to a bunch of old yeah
it really is really funny hold on that's
the joke um
oh uh dumb and dumber wow good job you
just stay up there i was gonna say
just stay up there yeah oh cloudy with a
chance of meatballs oh wow it's good
it's really good
oh the burger good burger nina and kel
tony orlando size me
yeah oh yeah wow
i mean should we name movies from the
80s
i mean i don't know stop motion
it was a departure it was a departure
from the movie
eugene i just yelled it louder
[Music]
you